hello this is Matthew from simply Lian
and today we're gonna cover docker
compose so in this session what we're
gonna do is we're going to go through
what daughter is and then by extension
what docker compose is and how it
improves the performance of docker
what the benefits of working with docker
compose is we are going to cover as well
what the difference between docker
compose and docker swarm is because the
two products are similar but they have
two different types of jobs and at the
end of this presentation we'll take you
through some basic commands that allow
you to get up and running working with
docker and docker compose finally after
this presentation we'll do a brief demo
that allows you to get up and running
using some of these commands to do your
own docker compose environment so let's
get started with docker compose so first
of all we have to kind of cover what
docker is so docker has come as an
evolution of technologies that started
with virtual machines vm machine and a
vm machine allows you to run in a
complete operating system and complete
operating system and its environment on
your own computer in your own operating
system without interfering that the
problem was is that it's very heavy and
complex and in contrast docker is a much
more lightweight and more flexible
environment that you can automate with
scripts so we have to remember that the
container itself is just software and it
has dependencies that one within that
application that are managed by Daka
so if we have a look at the way doctors
broke now first of all we have the
docker image and we have the docker
image created by a docker file and the
docker file is a text based script and
that text file within docker file
actually has all the commands that allow
you to run the appropriate technologies
within the docker image so the docker
image allows you to be able to have a
wide group of people and consistently
run the same environments and if you
want to be able to share that docker
image effectively you would do so by
uploading to docker hub and docker hub
can be available either publicly through
the dock the public docker hub website
or you can actually set up your own
prior Enterprise docker hub
share your own images across your own
network and then from dhaka how people
can then pull their own dog image and
build new containers that are consistent
on the original docker container that
you created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions will come up though is what if
you want to use two containers in a
single service and an example this might
be like a web server that is using a
database but the database may be in one
container and the web server may be in
another container which is very typical
for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar so I'm
sorry
how would you do this with docker so
what I usually just Ducker itself it's
actually very difficult to do this you
can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
composed you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment into what docker compose is
so let's consider a scenario that you'd
have today so Myntra is a fashion
website similar to Amazon and you go to
Metro with your web browser and on that
website you would go through a number of
activities such as logging into your
account browsing a catalogue you'd have
your checkout application server and you
go through the process of building out
an application behind each of these
services are different products such as
you know to have an account database
you'd have a product database different
checkout processes and these would all
be run behind the scenes and each of
these can be considered a micro service
so the more micro services you've build
into your environment the more
complexity you're adding and the more of
value it would be to have each of these
services in their own container but as a
developer you want to be able to jump
from one container to another container
so your login account can then be passed
on
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would just be small like what we're
showing right now where you'd have your
server in your database and you may have
a server running on Apache Tomcat or
sequel server you'd have different
databases and you want to be able to
have each of those in their own
containerized environment so the way
that duck compose runs is that it works
as a single service so you have the
docker compose running multiple
containers but the perception is of a
single service run the thing that's
great though is that each of those
containers or run in there in isolation
and but they can interact with each
other so unlike a normal doctor
environment where you have multiple
docker images running completely in
isolation of each other these are images
that will run in isolation but can
interact with each other the docker
compose files are very easy to write
they're all written with a scripting
language called camel and Yammer is an
xml-based language it actually stands
for yet another markup language but it's
an xml-based language and it's very easy
to use the great thing about learning
llamo is that a lot of open source tools
in the DevOps environment use yeah more
as the scripting Lane and then finally
in doc compose as a user you can add you
go and and trigger all your services
within the containers to start with a
single command as you can imagine this
dramatically reduces the amount of work
that you as a developer have to do so
let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with the new
jaques server and what with the Redis
database you can create a yamo command
docker compose file that actually has
the instructions on the containers
needed to build out both environments
and then you can run each of those
environments separately but have them
connected as a single service so the
benefits of docking compose is that you
have a single host deployment
environment you can run this all on one
piece of hardware you can have a quick
and easy configuration using Yammer
scripts the productivity that you get as
a developer significantly increases
because you know
to have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docket containers by
themselves you now have a way from being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you would have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docker compose isn't it
similar in concept to docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
composer so so doc composed will allow
you to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part I've been a single host which is
maybe your development PC with docker
swarm it also allows you to create
multiple contains however you have to
manage those multiple containers on
multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you are running in operations
environment but not so much if you're
doing a development environment and
docker compose is scripted with Yammer
which is very easy for you to be able to
control your scripts docker swamp
doesn't have a scripting technology like
Yammer so it's a little bit harder to
work with so what we have here is just
some basic commands that allow you to
get up and started working with docker
compose in our next demo right you can
take you through how to use all of those
come on so we're gonna go ahead and do a
demo on how to use docker compose the
first thing you want to do is check that
you have docker installed so we're going
to do is we're gonna open up the command
window and we're going to type in darker
you'll be able to see now that we have
docker installed if you don't have Doug
installed go ahead and install darker
you can go to Google search to install
docker and they'll give you the
instructions for that we also have
videos that we've already done if once
you have doc installed and you want to
do a google search on docker compose
we'll go to the docker comm website and
set for
the composed section and look for the
installed docker compose instructions so
we already have another tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of Ducker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section sect
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for Mac Windows and Linux
if you stalling on those platforms make
sure you copying the correct command
line so there's a couple command once
you want to copy copy the first one over
and we paste that in it's going to go
ahead and download all of the files for
compose I take some well but we have to
get another file so once downloading
we'll go get the other command line just
go back and grab it real quick a little
faster but we'll copy that over there
was a second command instruction and
post that commands yep there's the
command right there and that will apply
the appropriate binary and once you've
done that you're going to go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker - compose space - - version and
they will then give you a version build
once you know that you have a version
built that means that you have
everything installed correctly on your
machine so you can see here that we have
a version number which means we have
everything installed you might see a
different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but they were using real
content at the moment so just go ahead
and clear the screen and now what we're
going to do is create a folder where
we're actually going to install the ammo
file that will have the instructions for
dr. Coburn's environments so we're
moving the cursor to the desktop and on
the desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the mkdir command and
we'll call this one docker compose F for
file and then we'll move the cursor into
that new folder by using C key quad and
now we are in the folder called docker
compose F you go look at your desktop
and you'll see it's there and now you
want to select and pound touch
- composed yml and they'll actually
create the new Yama file for you and you
can use the LS list command LS docket -
compose dog mo and they'll allow you
actually now to step in and edit that
file so let's go ahead and hit return
and they'll allow us to go in and edit
the file so now I'm in the editor and
I'm going to write some instructions so
I'm gonna put a couple of mistakes in
these instructions so we can see how to
pose catches those mistakes so but most
this is gonna be fairly correct so you
can just type this out so we're gonna
start with surfaces : and we do web
kohalon and then would create image :
and we'll do nukes and then we'll do a
database cohort and we call the image
Redis and so what you can see because we
have two reference images we're actually
calling two different images two
different containers that will be
created by docker hub so what we're
going to do is where we can't just show
you how that's going in you can go to
docker hub and you can actually see the
references to the images that we've just
created so go to docker hub we just hold
hard calm and you'll see that and new
jaques Redis those are the default names
for the images so you could do other
images like HTTP for Apache web server
if you wanted to there are a lot of
images in docker hub so suddenly have a
lot of fun building tools from that
environment so we're gonna save those
files in the dock amateur which is can
do : WQ to exit this screen a save Thea
text and this gun run our Yama file and
you'll see the two different error
messages that will come up so we in
Duquette docker - compose des yml and
here we have display of the text that we
just wrote and now let's go check the
validity of the file that we just
corrected so we do doctor - compose
config and we should get an error
message and there we are
error message and the reason why we have
an error message is because the spacing
is not correct
in the yamo file itself so let's go to
the actual llamo file they've created
let's go through and we're going to use
just the file finder and you let's just
open up the gamal file in your text and
see your favorite text editor and here
we have the code that created it and
that's use the correct spacing so that
everything is spaced out appropriately
in the image and so this is the spacing
that you'd expect to see a space aligned
between surfaces and the first image and
the first image is a tab in and then it
reference what the image is and let's go
ahead and clear the screen and we'll see
whether or not we've got that all
correct it clear this clear screen and
we're going to check that everything is
running correctly and we're seeing we're
still getting an error message and the
reason why we're getting another error
is that there's still a config error in
this the actual yema file so one things
you have to do when you're creating a
llamó file for composers you actually
have to have the appropriate version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions 1 2 & 3 depending on the
age of docker that you have installed on
your computer so if you have the very
latest version of docker 18 in newer you
had put 3.7 as the version number and
what we're gonna do is we have just
check on the version that we have
installed and so just clear the screen
and then we'll just do docker version
and what we have is our jump Dockers
17.1 2 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose it's your main docker
environment and so we go back to our web
browser
we'll let you see that version 17 should
align with version number 3.5 yep there
we are version 3.5 so what we want to do
is go back into my mo file the very
first line that we want to put in above
the services is the version number and
that version number will get put in is
3.5 so we type in version version and we
put : and then version number is in
bright in quotes you save that and now
what I can't you do is we can actually
go ahead and use the single line
instruction to run both of these two
images that we created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
dr. Campos works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then puts the image the app
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docket - compose ah -
Dee and it's going to create the two
environments we have the women right in
the database environments and this use
sudo docker PS to actually list out that
all the processes that are running right
now and there we are we actually see all
of the images are running we have the
names the commands the images and
everything's up from running and if we
want to close both of those images we
can actually use a single line of
command as well and that command will be
sudo docker - compose down and that
closes both all the images and we see
that all the databases and the Web
Services images have been closed and
sudo dr. PS what she lists that there is
nothing running and that's how to use
docker compose and that's the end of our
presentation if you have any questions
please post your questions in the
comments below we always like to hear
your questions we'll answer all the ones
that we see if you like the videos and
you want to see more hit the subscribe
button if you want it then after you've
hit the subscribe button hit the bell
you'll then be notified as we upload
videos because we do multiple videos
every single week
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here